now you have to find a way not to let
these boring people rob you of your
precociousness
what you've got to do is this
don't mess with the grand diva
don't mess with the grandeur yes
sonali would you take archie as your
lovely wedded wife i do
argy would you take sonali as their
lovely wedded husband
i do different
he's wonderful he's your funny boy and
you
are different hello welcome to victoria
academy arjun shivaratnam
every human creature is constituted to
be
that profound secret and mystery to
every other
hi so who cares if he's single lease
amma
i like him auntie will never be allowed
into any of our houses if she marries
the singer
i saw you both it's dangerous and it's
and children old illegal simply because
we are damned
i just can't we don't want you here
anymore
so what do we do
will it make you happy why does everyone
say i'm funny
what does that mean
are you only eight years old what do you
know about love
[Music]
don't mess with the grand diva
you